I think if a woman is around a man for
an extended period of time a good man
that is with a good head on his
shoulders he will make her better and so
he will protect her from all like the
feminist ideologies crazy friends for
example if a friend is Whispering
something in your ear and you go to your
boyfriend you say what do you think
about this you know your boyfriend's
going to knock that out of you and be
like no that's rubbish and he'll show
you the direction you know I definitely
have that relationship with my brother
anyway I could tell my brother oh what
do you think of this and he he'll sort
of put me back on track that's why I
think a lot of women who stay single for
an extended period of Time end up a
little bit crazy when you see those like
single older women with like no kids
never married they're a little bit crazy
you know because they have no masculine
stability and logical Man by her side to
Keep Her On Track keep her from all
these like crazy delusions that the
world is throwing at her